noticed you've copied my beard
oh by the way this is a friend of mine
tree i
am thrilled i am steve rogers
hey everybody it's charlie we got all
kinds of avengers 4 marvel news to talk
about because of what's going on with
guardians of the galaxy
you may have heard about them changing
the plot for the guardians characters
during avengers 4.
they already shot a bunch of footage
last year but dave bautista gave us some
information about how they were changing
that because now guardians 3 is on a
semi permanent hold even though disney
intends to eventually make that movie
they want to give those characters more
closure at the end of the movie than
they originally had intended because
they were going to go right off to
guardians 3 and that was going to pick
up after the events of avengers 4.
so there's all kinds of rearranging
going on behind the scenes and also
there's the james gunn news about him
leaving to go do suicide squad too
so a couple really big things and i have
a really cool update on the fox disney
deal that i'll talk about at the end of
the video
there's a giveaway for the spider-man
game that's also going on this week all
you have to do to enter that is just be
a subscriber and leave a marvel related
comment on the video
so because of all this avengers 4
guardian stuff that's going on behind
the scenes
dave bautista has been promoting other
movies talking about the reshoots
saying that he already shot a bunch of
really good scenes last year that he
hopes that they don't cut out of the
movie because he didn't know how disney
was going to treat this whole james gunn
thing
and whether or not they were going to
cut a whole bunch of their story out or
kill them
off guardian is a galaxy that's a
franchise as well yeah are we going to
see any more of those
i believe so yeah we've definitely seen
more guardians in the upcoming avengers
which we've already shot at yeah
the last time we see the avengers they
were crumbled to dust which distressed
my son completely
which oddly enough i you know i i guess
i wasn't supposed to say anything but i
was already saying
before the uh guardians 3 i'm sorry
avengers 3 was released that i had
already filmed
four yes and i was signed up for
guardians three so
yeah i've shot scenes in it so uh yeah
somehow
it's gone that's comforting though isn't
it for a character to know you are back
it's comforting but at the same time i
felt a sense of guilt because i don't
know if i was supposed to say anything
you may have seen a lot of conspiracy
theorists feeling like they're going to
kill a bunch of those characters off or
not
bring some of the characters back that
died during infinity war
originally what was going to happen was
is that guardians 3 was going to be the
last movie with this roster some of them
would never come back
some of them would probably cameo in
other people's movies because of all the
space-based stuff that they're setting
up in captain marvel
they've been talking about quasar nova
movies just a whole bunch of other
space-based franchises that characters
can pop
up in you don't necessarily have to keep
doing guardians films
logically what that meant was is that
all the guardians characters that died
in one way or another during infinity
war would come back during avengers 4
they would go to guardians 3 say their
goodbyes to everyone have their big
final arc
introduce adam warlock to the universe
and hopefully send him into another
franchise but even with all that
craziness and the changes going on
there's still a couple arcs that they
have to pay off that you can bank on
they have to pay off nebula's arc she
has to get revenge on thanos and save
her sister which is why i'm hoping that
if anybody actually gets to kill
thanos it's nebula even though there are
a number of characters that could do it
and even though josh brolin wants to
come back as thanos they have to
complete his arc too he's one of the
most powerful people in the universe so
they have to find some way to balance
that
either you have a big reversal of his
plot during infinity war and he winds up
trapped in the soul gem and that's how
they contain him
mark ruffalo revealed last year when
they were filming it that they didn't
actually have the ending in mind so a
lot of the reshoots were dedicated to
capping the story off and turning it
into a real movie but the other big news
of the day
james gunn going to dc to do their
suicide squad sequel
here's the hot scoop though this
actually just broke while i was working
on this story
the movie that james gunn would be
making would not actually be a sequel
if he really does wind up doing the
suicide squad movie it'll be a
completely
reimagined version of those characters
meaning that he could recast some of
them he'll probably cycle the roster
and it will look completely different so
think them going from andrew garfield
amazing spider-man
to tom holland mcu spider-man you know
looks completely different even though
it's the same character within the span
of a couple years
there hasn't been any talk of him
working on other dc projects like say
the green lantern corps movie or new
gods or something else
a long time ago people used to ask him
all the time if you could do a movie at
dc
what would it be and he said that he was
a big fan of the metal men which is
obviously a really weird group of
characters which is what
the guardians were like he's a big fan
of doing these underdogs that nobody
really cares about
super fun and fight with the best of
them hey
maybe we could get together and discuss
thermodynamics
robots don't act like this your
responseometers must be malfunctioning
this looks interesting what's this i
wonder what this one does
we're under attack from evil destroy
evil
no wait don't worry doc we'll protect
you
there was originally someone else
working on suicide squad 2 called gavin
o'connor but they found when he turned
his script in it was almost identical to
the plot
of the birds of prey harley quinn movie
in that movie got fast track so that
means that they threw his
suicide squad script in the garbage can
he left the project
which is when warner brothers went
calling to james gunn because of all the
trouble that he had at disney recently
he's one of the biggest directors in
hollywood he's had a lot of big
successes we know that he's a good
writer
and a good director but he's in dire
need of a chance
so you can see why they were probably
more willing to hire him than say like
another studio for another big project
for those of you that really want to see
him collaborate on a green lantern core
film and have them turn that into a
really big franchise and use is
as a sort of second opportunity to do a
big connected universe the thing is is
that since james gunn's career blew up
after the first guardians film
he typically doesn't direct films that
he doesn't also
write himself and right now jeff johns
has that project he's writing the green
lantern corps movie as we speak
the same thing is going on with the new
gods movie ava duvernay
is writing and directing that right now
if everything goes well and he's able to
reignite that franchise and get
everybody really excited about suicide
squad i think warner brothers will try
to keep him around
let me know in the comments though james
gunn gets to recast
all these suicide squad characters who
do you want him to keep
and who do you want him to get rid of
right now jared leto is the joker is
kind of on the fence
he's already signed on for the morbius
movie and they're shooting that in
february
there's all kinds of dc movies involving
him that are at the
maybe status like maybe it'll happen
maybe it won't happen
nothing is concrete the only one i would
say he definitely does not recast
would be margot robbie just because
she's already doing so many other films
at dc it would be weird to see multiple
versions of her character
we've already got two versions of the
joker now let's not make this more
confusing than it has to be
another hot off the presses scoop is
that the fox disney deal is supposed to
be done by january 1st
and that doesn't include everything
that's mostly their corporate structure
and a lot of the behind the scenes stuff
they did say the actual regulatory
filings could drag that date out a
little bit
but it sounds like the deal is going to
close way sooner than before i know you
got all kinds of theories about how they
can introduce
x-men ideas in post-credit scenes for
avengers 4 and how they can reference
stuff that they might be rebooting later
on
so i'll do a separate video for that no
worries i'm working on venom easter eggs
and a whole bunch of other marvel videos
leave your requests in the comments
below i'll just leave the giveaway open
until i post more marvel so as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel
you'll see all the videos so no worries
click here for that venom carnage teaser
and click here to learn all about iron
man's new armor during avengers 4.
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight